There is a colonial woman on the wing.
She is dressed in
traditional colonial garb!
Get off!
It's possible for people to
grab hold of the intercom,
but we have special codes to be able to
get our voice across.
Hi, I'm Kristine Fernandez.
I was an international flight attendant
for a premium airline
for about seven years.
I was based in Dubai
and have experience working in first class
and as a senior leading the cabin crew.
Today, I'll be looking at
flight-attendant scenes
from movies and judging how real they are.
Come aboard, Mr. Young, Miss Chu.
Here's the way to your private suite.
And some Champagne.
I love this one!
I felt like that was the
airline that I worked for.
So, the bar that they walk into, you know,
that's almost exactly what it looked like.
So that for us would be
the business-class bar.
First class is insane.
You have your own private suite
where the doors close automatically,
and the best part is the shower.
Yes, there is a shower spa.
In order to use that,
you have allocated time.
So it's 30 minutes,
and the flight attendants would go ahead
and set up the spa for you
so that all the towels are warm.
The floors are heated.
The floors are heated in
your shower spa on the plane.
So it's pretty wild.
And there's, like, a
refreshment drink afterwards.
It's very beautiful.
Nick, we can't afford this!
These pajamas are fancier
than any of my real clothes.
So, we hand out pajamas,
you have slippers.
So you have a small amenities kit,
which is, like, this size.
You have your toothbrush,
you have your socks and eye shades.
I think 10 out of 10.
Honestly, when I was
watching that bar scene,
I felt like I was back at —
I was like, oh, I know those people.
That's book's messy.
What's wrong with messy?
The first thing about that
clip that stood out to me
you wouldn't believe
was actually the hair,
because the uniform standards
of flight attendants
is so very specific,
especially for the airline
that I worked with.
So, all hair must be back, right?
So if it's shoulder-length hair
and it's not touching the shoulders,
you can have it down.
But anything longer than that,
then you have to have up,
definitely away from the face,
with a maximum of six bobby pins.
The reason why hair was up
was more from a hygiene perspective,
because you're in food service.
In the event of an emergency,
having your hair up is good.
So when the hair was out here,
I was like, not so much.
The way that most flight
attendants see the lavatory
is like it's a public toilet in dry air.
So it's like the least sexiest place
that anything can really go down.
Getting steamy in the
public toilet in the air
is very undesirable.
For most. For most.
But not ruling it out for everyone.
Will you have dinner with me?
OK, that was, like, a supercute moment,
but I'm really not
supposed to do that, so.
OK, well, Bangkok
can be really magical.
First of all,
having a cute passenger on board
that you're just like, mew, mew, mew,
quite rare.
But also to have that open flirtation
in the middle of the aisles,
probably someone on the side being like,
"Excuse me, can I have a drink?"
Or, "Excuse me, here's some rubbish."
So that flirtation, if
it were to really happen,
it would happen more in the galley,
because it's more quiet
and you can just sort
of chat with each other,
but definitely flirtation
can happen on the plane.
I used to get asked
if I would like to marry someone.
Someone once asked me, they were like,
"Give me your number, please."
And I was like, "I don't
think that's appropriate.
Would you like a drink instead?"
And then they were like, "I
promise I will call you."
And I'm like,
that's exactly why I'm
not giving you my number.
Maybe, like, a 6 out of 10.
There were a lot of things
happening in one scene
which may happen in different scenarios.
Miss, you cannot be up here.
Hello, Grandpa.
I'm sorry, I just want to
be here with my friends.
How often do we have to
deal with drunk passengers?
All the time. Pretty much every flight.
One of the cabins that we had
had a whole bar in it.
There would be people who would
do the whole entire flight,
13 to 14 hours, just at the bar.
We've had dancing.
We've had people go from, like,
being the quietest passengers
at the beginning of the flight to,
by the end of the hours of drinking
is like everyone's best friend,
inviting everyone to the holiday
that they're about to go to.
Passengers are not allowed
up here in first class.
It's policy. I'm sorry.
That's very true.
That's how strict it is.
Like, that's how real it is.
Miss.
Um, no, it's not me.
In the night flights, we walk
through the different cabins
just to check how everything is.
There were a lot of seats, and these guys
pretty much made their way into there
and then covered themselves in blankets
and basically did their whole
flight as business class.
It's not allowed, but it can happen.
Whatever you say, Stove.
It's Steve.
The touching is definitely not allowed.
Does it happen?
Sometimes, but we're really firm.
We're very stern,
because that's definitely
crossing the line.
So it's a direct confrontation
of, "That's not acceptable."
And if it continues —
it's never continued, so I've
never gone to that level.
I have an announcement too.
There is a colonial woman on the wing.
She is dressed in
traditional colonial garb!
Get off!
It's possible for people to
grab hold of the intercom.
It's knowing what buttons to press.
10 out of 10, plus more.
I can imagine it happening in real life.
[pilot grunting]
What the hell?!
Never would that happen,
but I did once get sent a photo
of a snake being on a plane.
I don't know where it came from,
but someone said, "This was on my flight.
And there was just a little,
little friendly little snake.
But never, not at this level.
One thing that you can expect
on a flight in first class
is a falcon.
Was something that even we're trained for
on the airline that I worked with.
Odd things happen on a plane.
My flatmate, she
delivered a baby on board.
On our flight, in all cabins,
everyone gets handed out
a hot towel to freshen up.
And one time I handed out this towel,
the guy, like, he took it,
and he just looked at me,
and then he was like,
and I was like, "yeah," like, you know,
and he's like ...
[laughs]
Like, he ate the hot towel!
I couldn't believe it.
What's up with the oxygen masks deploying?
Oh, sorry about that.
You're not gonna believe
what came out of the
[beep] instrument panel.
Definitely if there's anything
to be concerned about,
you can just go straight to the cockpit.
Like, anything emergency
1, just ring or go in.
Most of the time if
there's heavy turbulence,
the flight attendant
wouldn't be in the cockpit,
the captain would say
"for all crews to take their seats."
So even at that level, no
crew would be walking around.
So definitely, like,
a 0.5 out of 10.
Attendant: Sir, you're
going to have to check that.
Greg: I got it.
Attendant: No, I'm sorry.
That bag won't fit.
No, no, I'm not — hey!
I'm not checking my bag. OK?
OK. There's no need to
raise your voice, sir.
I'm not raising my voice.
This would be raising my voice to you!
This is 1,000% true.
It happens all the time.
I feel like I've had this exact
conversation with someone.
But I will say the flight
attendant's composure here
is also very real. That's
what's expected of you.
One time, I was still new.
Can't really land until everyone's seated,
but one guy really wanted
to go to the toilet,
and he kept on looking
at me like, "Can I go?"
And I was like, "No, you can't go."
He goes, "No, I'm going."
He brought, like,
he brought a plastic bag with him,
and he turned around,
and I didn't understand what he was doing.
And then, as it turns out,
he urinated in the bag,
and then he tied it up,
and then he put it in front of me.
And, like, what do you do?
Did that just happen in my real life?
You know what? Get your grubby
little paws off of my bag!
OK? It's not like I have a bomb in here!
It's not like I want to blow up the plane.
Sir!
I just want to stow my bag
according to your safety regulations!
Even if what you're saying is a joke
or even if it's completely hypothetical,
like, he was just angry,
but that's something that
would cause a flight to
be definitely delayed.
So if someone says that,
everyone would definitely be deplaned.
So there are some serious
repercussions around that.
Giving it a 9 out of 10.
I hear about it all the time,
I just never experienced it.
Sometimes it might be in business class,
'cause the suites can be shared.
One time, the guys in first class
rang all of the stations
just to let us know
that there was a couple
having sex in the shower spa.
What?
Tom: Crapper's got my foot.
Oh! OK, wait, let me help.
OK. OK, one, two, three.
The thing that stands out to me
is that's how small the toilet is.
That's the kind of space that
you would be working with.
That's the possible
things that could happen,
where your foot could actually
end up in the toilet bowl.
Return to your seats now, please.
Beat it, stew!
They can knock, knock, knock,
but there's, you know,
there's so much you can do.
But I don't believe any
specific protocol around that.
It would be like, "This is not safe,
because if turbulence happens, we can't,
two people can't be in the toilet,
let alone fasten seat
belts whilst, you know,"
so that's probably the angle
that it would come from.
It's like, you can't just assume
and jump the gun and be like,
"Guys, no sex allowed."
You just, you kind of leave it.
9 out of 10.
There is an oxygen mask up above you,
on a hidden shelf.
Before helping the people who love you,
put it on yourself.
So, the fake planes, for us,
we called them the simulators.
The overall setup of
it is pretty accurate.
The tone here was more like, you know,
they're sitting there
waiting for it to happen.
When you're in training college,
it's a bit more serious.
All of the tests, especially
the safety and security one,
they're known to be the
most stressful times.
There are so many things
that you've got to remember
beyond just the commands.
You've got to memorize things like,
how many doors are there?
Where are the fire extinguishers located?
They've got different
aircrafts to memorize.
So if you're working on this aircraft,
then you must know where all of the safety
and security equipment is
for that particular aircraft.
It's really treated like
a serious exam period.
Assess the window! Good to go!
Jump, jump!
Whoa! Yes. 11 seconds, a trainee record!
When they do the training
around safety, it's like that.
You're in the situation of
acting out an evacuation.
So you actually, you have to yell.
Like, you have to raise your voice.
You actually have to
act with that urgency.
We are to be able to evacuate a plane
with all different
quantities of passengers,
but 420 is for the larger aircrafts.
We have to be able to evacuate
that quantity of passengers in 90 seconds.
People think that flight attendants,
the front that you have is
very friendly and approachable
and therefore not really that serious,
but it's quite a serious role.
So much of it is really
about your role in safety,
and that's never, ever talked about.
Like, health emergencies,
they happen on the plane.
Well, we would describe sometimes the job
kind of like being like
swans, swimming swans.
At the top it's very
nice and smooth and calm,
and underneath you've got the little feet.
Overall, I'd say pretty
accurate. Like, 8 out of 10.
♪ Kiss you, kiss you ♪
♪ Give you my coat when you are cold ♪
I've never had anyone sing on a flight.
In terms of performing on the airline,
no.
And then especially romance,
like public, open romance.
The whole performance thing is definitely
not something that I've
experienced in real life.
Get out of the way!
Excuse me, sir. I have
to serve the beverages.
The truest thing about this clip
is probably just the bar cart
and someone trying to get
through and not being able to.
And so what flight
attendants do, sometimes,
you've let someone go through the toilet,
but you're halfway through
a big row of seats.
So sometimes you would just let them wait.
Just let them wait,
and they know that they
will wait, and that's OK.
Not really that realistic.
I'd say probably a 1.
There's even a story that went around
that someone put their
baby in the hat rack,
because they weren't sure
where to put the baby.
I hope you enjoyed this video.
If you did, go ahead and click the button
to watch some more.